all right guys before you guys watch
this Vlog I have something huge to
announce literally right now like right
now right now like right now I'm working
on the barbell Brigade Black Friday sale
okay look I'm drawing it out on a piece
of paper because before it becomes a
nice website like this everything starts
janky like this don't make fun of me
that's how I like to do things that's
like how I like to communicate I like to
go with pen and paper but anyways the
big big sales that are going on Black
Friday starts November 24th on a
Thursday at 7 00 p.m you don't want to
miss out okay because all supplements
are buy one get one half off got it even
our best selling sour gumming
pre-workout yes our brown sugar Boba
protein yes our immunity support which
is our electrolyte and vitamin C blend
in aqua the Pina it's delicious
pineapple yes our performance greens
with six superfoods yes our apparel goes
from 25 off to 50 off to 75 off okay on
some items which is crazy are mystery
boxes okay are 25 off all digital
programs are 25 off so it's our biggest
sale of the year you don't want to miss
out so make sure you mark your calendars
and uh follow the bottle Brigade IG
because every single day will be
announced it will be will be announcing
some of our highest inventory items in a
specific size so like extra large is or
Smalls or mediums so that you guys know
exactly where to go to bum rush because
I know a lot of things have sold out
really quick this year and I want
everyone to get what they want so go to
bottlebrigade.com on uh I mean every day
but most importantly November 24th at 7
00 PM Pacific Standard Time
hey monkey do you know what we're gonna
do
what are we doing
Rock what are we gonna do mister
party there the party there there's a
party going on there
yes give it CUNY
so that's our apartment right now
our short-term rental
as our house is getting built and
closing escrow
and what's a really CUNY thing that came
out of us
um doing that get lean challenge is like
realizing the importance of walking for
both like not just you know trying to
lose weight but also just overall
cardiovascular health and just getting
our steps in as we call it and so this
morning since I just came back from JK
news
we were like oh let's have spent some
CUNY family time together get some
breakfast because breakfast is always at
like that really like cozy comfy hour so
we decided to walk there and as you can
see
it's nowhere to be found it's actually
quite a distance away but I'm very very
proud of the little monkey Cheeto
because he's been walking with us so
much that his little endurance in his
legs is so dead now
you got good endurance
why are you smart
[Music]
oh no this glass got protected
oh yeah
that is smart is that why you brought a
backpack so you can have all the stuff
in there so you don't have to hold it
yeah yeah that's very small not too
heavy yeah I brought a little
stuff
you are so smart all that stuff yeah
yeah yeah
this guy speaks so much crazy bones my
little best friend right now and that's
a full-on person to leave to JK news
yeah me and him were like hey that's the
best super BFF oh that's my favorite
place that's my favorite hot BFF
hey hey
you told me to watch out for a glass and
he's stomping on it that's CUNY my best
friend
hey monkey teach me about the bushes
what would you just teach me about the
bushes can we walk in the bushes
there's bees and butterflies they hang
out in the same place yeah yeah oh okay
what are the bees doing there
oh and you know what they do with the
with the flower
juice they drink yeah they drink the
flowers like
and do you know what they do with it
they make honey
that's where Honey comes from
the yellow flowers
oh is that is that what you've been
learning
okay
so what I like about our CUNY little
area for our short-term rental right now
is we live up there and just down here
this is like super cute little like
Village Center it's literally like a
five minute walk like it's so cute
that's how we decided to walk this
morning it's like catching it's diarrhea
I don't know if it's humid oh God I
think it's human dude let's get out it's
not L.A are you kidding me it's probably
animal like a coyote or something
there's Tito's vodka there I'm pretty
sure oh no a dumps can't believe the
California isn't coming over
what's a cracker donkey crazy bones yeah
let's throw up oh yeah so it's like
super CUNY like that's all suburb right
and then you just come here and just
this tiny little like commercial area
with like a IHOP little mama pop
restaurant
supermarket and then one of our favorite
um breakfast places to go in Vegas it's
actually chains if you guys are ever in
Vegas come check it out it's called Egg
Works there's a bunch of them I think
there's like between five to eight and
it's technically a like Mom and Pop that
turned into a chain but it's not the
Nationwide chain like a Denny's you know
so it still has that Mom and Pop feel it
has like the Mom and Pop flavors and
it's really good and what's crazy is
right in this little center right to the
left and right of it is nothing again I
think all of that is like some corporate
skyrise area and then to that side is
all um more homes so it's just cunya
there's this this tiny little hot spot
that serves just the people that lives
around here so it feels very quaint and
cozy so like none of these places the
um Albertson CBS Starbucks nothing in
this little pocket ever gets packed
because it literally feels like it's
just made for just the suburb around
here just so cool
oh that's CUNY the street is literally
called Village Center because that's
what I called it I called it a Village
Center because that's what it felt like
oh really yeah and they named it exactly
the way I thought and then that is the
restaurant Egg Works their logos like a
little egg let's go Duty we gotta go the
cross Rock's on
airplane
see what I mean as soon as we're in the
dead center this intersection down there
is just like corporate buildings
so no one's there on the weekend because
it's like nine to five and over there
it's just more suburbs
so it's just literally like this little
corporate Village Center or not
corporate but commercial Village Center
to serve just the neighborhood around
here so all these like CUNY families can
come out and have a really nice
breakfast every morning
area
hey monkey Cheeto yeah yeah what sound
does this animal make
good job
let's go hoodies
this is my favorite part so the
weather's so nice right now that
everyone wants to sit outside so the
inside is actually pretty empty and it's
so much to the point where like I wanna
can we sit outside too and they're like
oh there's actually a weight I'm like oh
what this is usually almost never a wait
for outside you know what I mean usually
the weights for inside but that's how
nice the weather is right now dude
foreign
Vegas you got a ton of them look at this
CUNY view I get to eat with Mama and
then I got you with cutie pie where this
random toy came out and then we're just
out here enjoying the outside
so it doesn't matter what you get here
what they're really known for is their
banana bread and they make it into
banana the muffins banana bread all
kinds of stuff and that is it right
there it's so good is the banana bread
good here
it's hot oh it's a fresh one but he
can't wait
oh thank you monkey you're so sweet
it was kind of like
started not liking us first
that's what they're known for it's so
good
there's a little bit of coffee action
whoa it was almost gone
you know what's good when this guy
doesn't need to be told to eat and just
chowing down on it
that banana bread actually holds a
special place to my heart too because
when we first moved to Vegas
um our neighbor from across the street
like walked over like in the movies you
know they like offer pie to your new
neighbor I've never experienced that
before and they walked over with a loaf
of banana bread like hey welcome
neighbor we saw that you guys just moved
in so we want to welcome you guys in and
they brought over the banana bread and
they go this is our favorite restaurant
and we took it in and I ate it and I was
like
and so I think not only is the bread
good it has it gives me the warm and
fuzzies inside does it give you the warm
and fuzzies too they're so nice huh and
we never did it too any of the other
neighbors that came in we did we bought
85 degrees
to uh the families that moved in from
the side to side
for Christmas
and the one in the front
I'm just kidding
so this guy got the Yummy Yummies with
the breakfast potatoes oh by the way
they're Diablo potatoes you have to get
it's it's a red knuckle
Cajun seasoning yeah
we got extra egg whites New York steak
sub the potatoes for tomatoes fruit
tomatoes with potatoes and potatoes do
you have to eat this clean too I don't
have to but it makes my life easier so
that I'm not like apart I mean
I know so I like to do it
thank you thank you thanks I like to do
it in like modernization in moderation
yeah so like I'll have this then I'm
like okay let me balance that out with
this you're good I'm really good
so I wasn't even gonna Vlog this but it
this has been going on for the past like
five minutes
look at all this yeah there's so many
motorcycles that's great
I don't know her
look at that I love Vegas so much it is
the longest combo I've seen like this
just all kinds of motorcycles oh my God
well is that police escort too or
something
what is it
it's so rad
IUS
what there's a fire truck too
okay what is going on look at all these
guys all these like T-Rexes or whatever
they're called what is going on what is
this I gotta Google this is our race
cars okay wait a minute
okay that's the end of it what do you
think that was I have no idea
about it from the tree I don't know
what's going on between these two but
somehow Now Tiger challenge him to touch
the stick up here touch that stick right
there
look at poppy ready yeah
are you impressed with your dad are you
impressed
[Applause]
and that's pretty cool
let's see go go go oh no you didn't
you're gonna try to run he's gonna stop
himself too
so as you can see it's a walking kind of
day which is super CUNY oh my look at
that
that cloud looks insane that's cool
looking
wow I don't know what's going on
but anyways
it's a CUNY walking kind of day because
after breakfast you went home had a nice
little lazy day where we watched the new
uh the redeemed team documented on
Netflix about the USA basketball team
that came back and won Gold with Kobe in
it
you're Kobe you are and everyone took a
big old nap feel nice and refreshed
techa wanted to play so we're like you
know what let's go to the park then
we've brought a little soccer ball we're
a little football and a lot of Frisbee
and a little frisbee took a move around
and then we can go play and it's crazy
seeing this guy like you know we all
witnessed him walk or crawl first walk
learn how to run and now this guy you
can see this little athletic things like
going off in his mind and I just found
out he knows how to dribble
show everyone that you're not a dribble
wow that's amazing dude
I can grab the one I'm walking I know I
saw him yeah
would you rather be Jeremy Lin or Kobe
Colby yeah exactly exactly exactly
exactly play playing so all over uh
Vegas suburbs
there's a lot of really cool hidden gems
because I think they're really trying to
build out like this suburb feel so we're
just here walking like in a suburb
between like two neighborhoods or two
communities right and between a lot of
them they'll have these things called
the Paseo
and when you go into the Paseo it's like
this you got like a little Park
we don't have to worry about cars
kids could just do whatever have a good
old time feels nice and safe in here
have you been here before mister
my imagination the imagination
it's probably for the bridge is like
where I don't think I'm like you got to
use your imagination okay I wish for a
park puddle up and then it's gonna
appear
you would dude now you gotta go get it
mister
[Applause]
watch out you're gonna twist your ankle
can I tell you a secret and I hope it
never happens no what I hope it never
happened at this guys why are you gonna
share bad news we're gonna put bad news
out into the world but I'm also cheese
mosa what
I have never twisted my ankle my entire
life oh really yeah like no matter how
bad it's I've been like this like even
on a surfboard or whatever you have
never really ankle I don't know I think
I have like cat like reflexes in my
ankles and I never have yeah either that
I've never pushed my body though
[ __ ] sandbagger yeah
I should have brought a blanket
are you ready yeah here it comes
hey good job
ah almost
okay here it comes
so good
of course this guy and his wise ideas
he's like all right next one I'm gonna
go in the park
and then I'm gonna throw it to you
okay where are you gonna throw it from
right here
yeah go ahead
to the grass are you even gonna make it
look how far the grass is
okay I'm right here
it didn't even make it to the grass
okay here it comes ready yeah
here it comes
hey good job all right we're back at our
favorite Argentinian restaurant
the only place is where I can stay on a
diet get high protein have something
extremely flavorful and can I admit
something
it's only 450 technically like five
and I've been liking these early dinners
that we've been having I know it's a
super Boomer thing but you know right we
used to want to eat at nine remember
nine ten dinner time but now we've been
liking the the dinner at five because
look ain't nobody here ain't no weight
so you get time they technically come in
and out and you can go some of the best
restaurants you can go in at like 4 45
and ain't nobody there and guess what
you eat get great service because
they're not even busy and then you go
home and then you go home at like six in
your bed by 8 30. you're in bed by 8 30
oh my God that's the life man
it's gotta take every cell in my body to
resist oh I love bread or chimichurri
oh my dear oh my oh
stay strict play a player I'm only gonna
get I'm only gonna get steak and a salad
that's it
always hot always it's perfect it's
perfect I was just a place that has
chimichurri by the flavor of the
chimichurri and this place and one more
I think it's called 1810 yeah I love 18
seconds uh in Pasadena or in L.A uh it
has really good chimichurri this is the
other one and look at their Empanada
cheese
it's a dumpling dude oh okay
yeah we got some rice some salad toss it
up some olive oil
time see look at this we finished all of
our dinner right and look at what time
it is
5 30. that's what happens when you come
early
you ate all that food in 30 minutes on
with our day Boomer life baby
and Ty could do a really good job
getting everything ready for the week I
gotta get up all this toys so we had a
cool little fun center put a little
foldable mattress out put that away
getting everything sorted away for the
weeks we could hit Monday running
so while that's all cleaned up
so it's a fridge we threw out all the
unnecessary food that's what we did yup
yup that's what we did we organized all
the food and now we're a lot of people
and when I do something and then now
we're gonna just fold all these clothes
oh we're not it's just you
it's gonna put all these clothes just
you know trying to Alley you for the
week so we can dunk hard on Monday baby
thank you guys for hanging out with us
and we will see you tomorrow
[Music]